you
[Music]
this morning on the dish a chef whose
reputation is as big as the state he
calls home
Texas based chef John T czar was born in
New York City and raised in the Hamptons
he got his start in the restaurant
business as a teen working at night and
surfing all day he went on to work at
some of the trendiest restaurants in New
York and Las Vegas earning notice for
his skills in the kitchen and for his
outsized personality
we eventually put down roots in Dallas
and in 2014 opened knife the steakhouse
reinvention made Esquires list of best
new restaurants of the year and knife is
also the title of his new cookbook chef
john tase our welcome to the dish good
morning well thank you for having me
tell us what we got on this great table
okay so we have a tomato and watermelon
salad very summer we have a pork belly
in the style of Peking duck has sriracha
we have our dry-aged steaks at knife
which we specialize in my macaroni and
cheese which we named after John McEnroe
and then we have this is a Texas
phenomenon we have avocado fries which
are tempura avocado and last but not
least a grilled apricot tart and our
beverage of choice Todd sweet tea extent
ulm and Jack and some peaches from 10-11
right here
Cheers oh you know so many chef's that
we've had here have been influenced by
their parents a parent your mother
influenced you in cooking my mother you
know I was adopted my parents are
Czechoslovakian but my mother during
World War two hung out with all these
Italian women they had a sewing club so
my mother learned how to cook all of
this amazing northern Italian food and
it was a great influence on me as a chef
and she was very strict disciplinarian
as we were growing up I didn't have junk
food and I didn't have soda so I think
in hindsight that helped me develop the
palette that I have today as a chef so
not only the exposure but just the
eating the clean food early on in my
life you you grew up in Queens basically
right I did my grandmother had a house
in a candy store in Queens my father was
a banker in Manhattan and we had a house
in the Hamptons as well right your first
job in the food industry was what
planing lettuce and tomato for burgers I
actually started washing dishes by hand
and that was my promotion was to put the
lettuce and tomatoes
so is my big promotion of the Sun
obviously did it well so how do you go
from doing that to getting sort of a
maybe more real job in the restaurant
industry you know I just I really was a
surfer in a skateboarder and I loved I
fell in love with the romance of the
restaurant business I worked in the
small pub in West Hampton Beach and
literally at the bar Jimmy Breslin
George Plimpton every soap pop you
noticed it was romance and excitement to
me so the romance was the people who
came in the atmosphere the conversations
you know the social stimulation I fell
in love with that that energy of the
restaurant business and luckily I had a
god-given talent to cook otherwise I
don't know what I'd be doing right now
you then move on obviously from there
and train and make your way eventually
to getting to Texas how did that happen
well you know I went to France cooking
school after the pub in West Hampton I
worked in a French restaurant that I
went to Paris I dropped out of school
and then I replaced Dean fairing at the
mansion on Turtle Creek which was an
amazing opportunity in position to take
and then I married a girl from West
Texas always following a girl we always
get you to come with us and then her
family was in the cattle ranching
business I started to learn about the
animal husbandry side of it and the
sourcing of Texas beef and that's how we
put together knife that along with going
to every Steakhouse in the country did
that change you in some way when you
when you when you got there and you and
you started that project you know I left
New York after 9/11 and I'd spent some
time in Lake Tahoe I came back to work
with Rick Moonen and then a headhunter
contacted me and said would you like to
replace Dean Ferenc and I was like it's
like one of those moments you take the
phone and pretend you're gonna like wait
and give an answer I was like I'm sure
I'll do that
yes but it was a competition I had to
cook off a bunch about I guess against a
hundred chefs to get the position Wow
and you know I fell in love with that
opportunity because it was a reinvention
of my career and it really changed my
life to replace Dean and we're still
close friends to this day is an amazing
gotta to change your life um it just
gave me an opportunity to refocus and to
be at the mansion to get back into fine
dining to get the hotel back to
five-star status it gave a lot of it yes
and it gave me a lot of attention on my
career and led to other opportunities so
and with the steak houses it's not just
a steakhouse the way we think of it
is it you know I was a seafood chef most
of my life but Texas is a meat and
potato kind of place so I was given the
opportunity of knife in the hotel with
the caveat that I had to do a steakhouse
so I literally went around to every
steakhouse in in the country to find out
what they had and didn't have to try to
reinvent it because I felt that Texas
needed that steakhouse like you know a
fish needs a bicycle so it's upright so
I really put my head to it and we found
sourcing and you know it's more of a
chef driven thing it's something you
can't really articulate you have to come
and experience it because it really is
about the flavor of the steak and the
product and the dry aging process that
we do well it is the dish so as you are
signing the dish yes ma'am you could
have a meal with anyone past or present
who would it be
you know just recently we were talking
about this in the green room I used to
work with Anthony Bourdain and such an
icon and we were friends at one time
we've been at odds do two magazine
articles about each other and comments
in books so I'd love to share a great
statement Anthony Bourdain might have
said something outrageous about you like
anime or the obverse but I would love to
sit around and have a couple of drinks
with him like we did back in the old
days yeah it'd be fun I'd be a fun meal
to actually be in on yes it would chef
John Key's our thank you so much thank
you very much and for more on John T's
our amma dish you can head to our
website at CBS this morning dot-com